화학에서 영감을 받은 거예요.
하지만 양자 머신러닝에서
영감을 받은 것들도 있다는 걸
기억해 두세요. 그리고 다른
근미래 알고리즘들, 예를 들면
양자 근사 최적화 알고리즘
같은 것들도 있어요.
화학 ansatz의 일반적인 선택지를
몇 가지 살펴볼게요.
Unitary coupled cluster, 즉 UCC는
최초의 VQE 논문에서
처음 제안된 방법이고,
양자 화학 문제에서
흔히 사용돼요.
보통 양자 상태를 파라미터화할 때,
지수적으로 많은 파라미터를
다루게 돼요.
그런데 준비 circuit을 효율적으로
만들려면,
다항식 수의 연산이
필요하고
따라서 다항식 수의
파라미터가 필요해요.
UCC는 그런 circuit으로
시험 상태를 준비하는 방법의 예시인데,
coupled cluster 방법에서
유래했어요.
그게 바로 양자 화학에서의
황금 표준이거든요.
가장 일반적인 선택은
unitary coupled cluster
singles and doubles ansatz,
줄여서 UCCSD예요.
UCCSD는 문제의 특정 전자 배열에서
동기를 받기 때문에,
시스템을 제대로 반영하는
레퍼런스 상태가 필요해요.
그게 바로 Hartree-Fock 상태예요.
UCCSD ansatz는 보통 바닥 상태를
잘 근사해요.
주어진 분자에서 단일 및 이중
전자 여기를 잡아내기 때문이에요.
UCCSD의 파라미터 수는
스핀 궤도함수 수의
제곱에 비례해서 늘어나요.
UCCSD는 문제에 맞게
잘 조정할 수 있지만,
안타깝게도 제곱 스케일링은
여전히 매우 깊은 circuit으로 이어지고,
그게 현재 양자 컴퓨터에는
어려운 부분이에요.
그래서 IBM 연구자들이 더 휴리스틱한
접근법을 제안했어요.
variational form을 하드웨어에
맞게 조정할 수 있는 방법인데,
효율적으로 실행 가능한
circuit을 만들어줘요.
즉, 시험 상태가 quantum gate들로
파라미터화되고,
실제 물리 장치에
맞게 적응돼요.
이건 하드웨어 친화적인
매우 휴리스틱한 접근법이에요.
이 예시들을 바탕으로,
variational form을 표현하는 데
우리가 가진 가능성의
스펙트럼을 살펴볼게요.
이것들 중 많은 부분이
이미 Qiskit에 구현되어 있어요.
그러니 직접 시도해 보길 권해요.
어떤 게 풀고자 하는 문제에
가장 적합한지 알아보세요.
그래프를 보면, 한쪽에는
매우 휴리스틱한
variational form들이 있어요.
문제 특수성은 낮지만,
실제 하드웨어에서 구현되도록
설계된 것들이에요.
또한 높은 표현력을 가지고 있어요.
다시 말해
이것들로 많은 양자 상태를
표현할 수 있다는 의미예요.
하지만 나중에 고전적 최적화
단계에서 문제가 생길 수 있어요.
바로 고전적 최적화 과정에서
맞닥뜨리는
소위 barren plateau 문제인데,
다음 모듈에서 다룰 거예요.
반대편에는 문제 특수성이
높은 unitary
coupled cluster가 있어요. 고전 화학에서는
뛰어난 성능을 보이지만,